you
I think that online dating is just the
newest way to do the same old thing as a
matter of fact I think it's actually a
little bit more natural first of all
it's it's the people are doing it and a
lot more people are going to do it and
they're going to do it because we're no
longer marrying the boy we met in high
school we're not marrying the girl we
met in college we're not even marrying
in our early 20s and by your late 20s
you sort of know everybody in the office
you know you've gone through all those
boys you know you met everybody in your
social circle where are you going to
meet people and also with a very high
divorce rate there's a lot of people who
are back in the dating game in their mid
30s mid 40s mid 50s and higher and you
can't stand in the middle of Park Avenue
in New York City and flap your dress up
and down I mean at some point you've got
to find a new way of social networking
and all these dating services are doing
that and among the young people it's
Twitter and Facebook and other social
networks so I think that you know the
human animal loves we were born to love
and we do it all our lives it's the same
brain system whether you're ten years
old or whether you're 90 years old
children do fall in love the sexual
component might not be there but they
will become intensely attracted to
another child I certainly older people
fall in love this good data now that
this brain system does not change with
age and we've got a society where people
are very peripatetic almost nomadic and
all of these internet dating sites are a
way to meet new people and in many
respects I think that it's actually more
natural I know that sounds odd because
we're used to walking into a bar and
going up and talking to somebody who we
have we don't know anything about them
we don't know if they're married we
don't know if they're in town for the
night we have know nothing about them
and we seem to think that that's natural
but actually it's much more natural to
meet somebody having already known what
they do for a living
how old they are what some of their
goals are what their interests are you
know for millions of years we traveled
in these little hunting and gathering
bands on the grasslands of Africa and
the young girl might not know you know
that cute boy over the next fire place
but you know her father knows his uncle
her mother knows his niece and there's
so many gossip circles that she can find
out probably in an hour whether he's a
good dancer whether he's got a good
sense of humor whether he's likely to be
a loyal partner and so with these new
you know networking sites you do get to
know some basic things about somebody
before you meet them and that's more
natural
I've always maintained that you know
that it's exactly the same brain system
I mean gay or straight have the same
brain system for fear they got the same
brain system for curiosity they got the
same brain system for stubbornness and i
think that the brain system for a
romantic love is exactly the same who
you fall in love with that's different
but how you feel when you love that i
think is the same and i did a
questionnaire study of 800 people 400 in
the united states and 400 in japan and i
had quite a significant homosexual
subpopulation who took my questionnaire
and i didn't find any difference at all
in the basic characteristics between
those who expressed romantic love and
were heterosexual and those who are
homosexual I think we actually make too
much of homosexuality it's a little like
we've made too much of skin color and
now we're making too much of
homosexuality because I mean as I say
whether you're a curious person doesn't
mean whether you're gay or straight
doesn't add to whether you're curious or
whether you're good at math or whether
they've got a good sense of humor or we
seem to I think we've way over
misunderstood how really insignificant
how small a part of the brain that is